This is my custom coded website, and
every single day Claude does research on
my niche, finds trending or relevant
topics, write the articles, and then the
article is posted directly over to my
website without me lifting a finger.
Let's show you how you can set up this
workflow for yourself. So, first we're
going to want to use Claude code for
this setup. The reason why we're using
Claude code is because now we're
implementing and using the WordRocket
API. Because our website is custom
coded, we obviously cannot use our
WordPress integration that we have with
WordRocket. So, in order to get this to
work, there's a couple of different
steps in which you need to do. The first
set is that you need to connect your
custom site's publishing API to Claude.
So, before talking to Claude, make sure
that you have a publish endpoint, a
secret API key, a bearer token, and so
on and so forth. Now, you don't need to
know or to be technical to know exactly
how to do this.
All you need to do is follow this prompt
and put it into Claude. If you want to
get the full prompt and SOP, comment
Claude below and I'll send it over to
you. This prompt will essentially
connect Claude over to your API. Within
the prompt, you need to enter in your
API key. So, head over to
app.wordrocket.ai. You need to ensure
that you're on a lifetime agency plan or
higher or a premium monthly plan. And
then under API keys, you can generate a
new API key, copy over that API key, and
you're going to put that into Claude so
that it can connect uh
to WordRocket from the API. The beauty
about this workflow is that we can
actually create a routine. So, a routine
is a templatized routine that can be
kicked off on schedule by API or by a
webhook. So, as you can see here, we've
went ahead and created this full
routine. Step one is going to pick
today's topic based upon the
instructions that I gave it. It's going
to research the topic. It's going to
generate the topic using the WordRocket
MCP, and then it's going to
um get the AI generated image, construct
the API payload. So, essentially it's
going to construct the payload with the
article and then send it over to your
blog API, and then come back and tell
you that everything is done. And we can
set this up to be done every single day
at 8:00 a.m.
So, as you can see, we've already done
two different runs. So, if you go ahead
and take a look at these two runs, we
can open up these links, and we can see
that right onto WordRocket, our articles
have been posted. They have title tags.
They have um they're nicely formatted.
They have TLDR. Beautiful images
included here.
And we can see the article has been post
We can see that the article has been
posted directly over to WordRocket with
our tags, our H1s, our images, our TLDR,
our key takeaways, and the information
just looks really, really good.
That was the first article in which we
generated. We made some tweaks to the
prompt, and now as you can see, this
article is much longer. That first
article was 5 minutes. This article is
11 minute read. So, much, much more
in-depth and more like a long-tail
article that we would get back from
WordRocket. So, we can see here,
everything here is really, really
in-depth, really long,
and as you can see, it's on up-to-date
content. This is about Claude Opus 4.7,
which was just launched a couple of days
ago. So, you can set it up to do live
web research on topics or that are
trending, on news articles, on new
releases, on anything that you can think
of. And even you can even do this for
evergreen content as well. And I really,
really like this because again, we're
interacting with Claude. So, Claude will
do its best to find the best possible
topic, get better information, and send
that over to WordRocket.
So, if I actually go ahead and take a
look at my content in WordRocket, we can
see that these were the two articles
that were sent over by the API. So, it
was sent over, and it was generated
directly into WordRocket. It literally
took me hours to set up, but I've got
the process down right. And if you want
to get the full access to the prompt and
the SOP, just comment Claude below and
I'll send it over.
And again, if And of course, if you'd
like to use WordRocket for yourselves,
head over to app.wordrocket.ai.
If you want to see exactly how to set up
your MCP onto Claude so it can connect
to Claude so we can write the content on
WordRocket, I'll link some other
tutorials in which I've already
Hope that you guys enjoyed today's
video, and I'll see you in the next one.
Take care.